yo no descarto un acuerdo con ninguna
ecuatoriana con ningún ecuatoriano que
actúe de buena fe que comprenda que está
por por delante un gran objetivo que es
sacar adelante el país lo que más
representa guillermo lasso es quizás su
mayor lastre en un ecuador escéptico con
los banqueros aunque siempre reivindicó
sus orígenes humildes que le llevaron a
iniciarse en el mercado laboral con 15
años fue durante casi 20 años presidente
del banco de guayaquil llegó a la
política en 1998 como gobernador de la
provincia de guayas y al año siguiente
se convirtió en súper ministro de
economía eran años de crisis en el país
andino había una contracción del crédito
y una falta de liquidez en el sistema
financiero que ocasionó que la mayoría
de sus clientes perdiera una parte de
sus ahorros ecuador estaba hundido en el
desempleo y la inflación y en 2000
adoptó el dólar como moneda oficial
en 2013 guillermo lasso se presentó a
las elecciones presidenciales pero
perdió ante el entonces presidente
rafael correa quien le superó por el
doble de votos en 2017 laso se midió con
lenin moreno el candidato de correa
quien venció en unos comicios que
terminaron en un recuento parcial de
votos tras denuncias de fraude por parte
de la so conservador cercano al opus dei
es un firme opositor al derecho al
aborto y en campaña trató de convencer a
los sectores populares con la promesa de
acabar con el hambre de más de un millón
de ecuatorianos buscó solucionar el
problema de empleo promoviendo inversión
inversión privada local internacional en
sectores estratégicos de la economía
ecuatoriana del sector público en el
sector petrolero en el sector eléctrico
en el sector de la telecomunicación con
su presidencia se reivindica como el
gestor que puede hacer por fin despegar
la economía de ecuador de la mano del
fondo monetario internacional y
asegurando que evitará que ecuador se
convierta en una nueva venezuela